[Aplausos]
[Música]
egipto es el país más grande del mundo
árabe con más de 95 millones de
habitantes y si ya se lo que estáis
pensando indonesia o pakistán son mucho
más grandes que egipto y también tienen
mayoría musulmana verdad pues si tenéis
razón pero tenemos que distinguir entre
árabe y musulmán
el islam es una religión el árabe es una
cultura una raza y sobre todo un idioma
y dentro del mundo árabe egipto es el
país más grande y uno de los más
influyentes eso explica que la liga de
fútbol árabe tenga su sede en la plaza
tahrir en el corazón de el cairo aunque
noticias como ésta sean tan preocupantes
egipto eleva a 305 muertos el balance
del peor atentado de su historia sin
embargo pese a las últimas noticias
egipto está cambiando mucho más rápido
de lo que nos podríamos imaginar
recordáis las primaveras árabes en 2011
miles de personas se manifestaron
durante días hasta derrocar al dictador
hosni mubarak un año después los
hermanos musulmanes se hacían con el
poder dispuestos a convertir el país de
las pirámides en una república islámica
[Música]
pero ahora en 2017 la política egipcia
ha dado un giro de 180 grados tanto como
para ver noticias como esta
[Música]
el gobierno egipcio cierra 27000
mezquitas para luchar contra el
terrorismo así que ahora os preguntaréis
cómo hemos llegado hasta aquí se está
convirtiendo egipto en un país secular
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
los hermanos musulmanes hay tres nombres
que definen la historia de egipto en los
últimos 60 años
nasser sadat y mubarak los tres tienen
un elemento en común presidían una
dictadura guiada por los principios del
socialismo árabe que como ya sabéis era
la ideología de moda en la época bien es
cierto que esa edad reconoció el estado
de israel y luego mubarak es el que
vivió la caída definitiva del bloque
soviético
sin embargo pese a ser tan socialistas
ninguno de los dos tuvo problemas en
cambiar los rublos por dólares y
convertirse de la noche a la mañana en
firmes aliados de eeuu pero como ya
sabéis ser amigo de los eeuu tiene
también sus problemas normalmente suele
convertirte en objetivo de los radicales
islámicos y por eso mubarak aplasto con
firmeza cualquier movimiento islamista
cualquier elemento bien por atentados
que hubo unos cuantos en los años 90 o
bien porque estos radicales pudieron
suponer una amenaza para su poder
con este panorama poco espacio tenía la
oposición contra mubarak de hecho a que
no adivinan quién era el único grupo
organizado que se ponía en frente del
dictador efectivamente los hermanos
musulmanes a pesar de operar en la
clandestinidad proscritos desde el año
1954 la cofradía de los hermanos
musulmanes es el movimiento político
mejor organizado de egipto desde que
logró la independencia con miles de
militantes de base y millones de
simpatizantes
su objetivo es convertir a egipto en una
república islámica adoptando la sharía
como ley y el corán como su guía
política sin embargo los hermanos
musulmanes no son el único grupo
integrista que hay en egipto en este
mismo país nos encontramos también a los
salafistas que persiguen los mismos
fines pero de una forma totalmente
distinta fijaos estos señores que
aparecen en la pantalla son hermanos
musulmanes si os fijáis veréis que
visten como una occidental verdad
pantalones vaqueros camisetas sudaderas
etcétera
sin embargo ahora os pongo imágenes de
militantes salafistas veis la diferencia
los salafistas llevan el atuendo
tradicional islámico con su barba y su
ce viva en la frente de tanto postrarse
fervorosamente hacia la meca como su
propio nombre indica los salafistas
quieren vivir como vivían los llamados
salad es decir los primeros musulmanes
cuando hablan no dejan lugar a dudas
sobre cuáles son sus objetivos políticos
y religiosos
los hermanos musulmanes por su parte son
mucho más pragmáticos de entrada están
mucho mejor organizados
[Música]
y filtran a sus miembros en las
instituciones de gobierno y no tienen
problema en hablar con medios
occidentales para lanzar mensajes como
éste
no somos terroristas la filosofía de los
hermanos musulmanes está inspirada por
un entendimiento del islam que enfatiza
los valores de la justicia social la
igualdad y el estado de derecho y jan el
haddad portavoz de los hermanos
musulmanes en otras palabras que tanto
los salafistas como los hermanos
musulmanes tienen los mismos objetivos
pero distintas estrategias de hecho los
salafistas se presentan a las elecciones
por un partido político totalmente
distinto el partido al nour y como os
podéis imaginar los radicales no se
llevan bien entre ellos en realidad se
odian mutuamente
[Música]
en cualquier caso durante los años 80 la
dictadura militar de hosni mubarak
reprimió a estos dos grupos a partes
iguales desde el año 1981
egipto ha vivido un estado de emergencia
donde se metía en la cárcel a todos los
disidentes políticos hablamos de miles
de sara pistas y de hermanos musulmanes
que pasaron décadas en la cárcel y como
os podéis imaginar ni la unión europea
ni eeuu hicieron nada para evitar esta
represión a fin de cuentas nadie quería
ver los radicales islamistas en el
gobierno
[Música]
por si esto fuera poco tras la guerra
del yom kipur egipto se había convertido
en un buen aliado de israel y su
economía estaba aún fire
si algo tiene este país desde la
antigüedad son los ingredientes
perfectos para ser un paraíso del
turismo se puede decir que hacia el año
2000 no te daban un carnet oficial de
viajero si no te habías hecho un crucero
por el nilo o no tenías una foto con las
pirámides así que durante 30 años
mubarak tuvo carta blanca para gobernar
egipto pero esperad un momento porque en
el año 2011 las cosas cambiaron
[Música]
mubarak señala la sucesión en egipto
llevando a su hijo a washington esta
noticia desató las iras de muchos
ciudadanos y del propio ejército una
cosa es tener un dictador y otra muy
distinta es tener una dinastía de
gobierno hereditaria así es cómo surgió
la primavera árabe que terminó
derrocando a mubarak
[Música]
un año después se celebraron elecciones
parlamentarias y presidenciales hablamos
de un país que llevaba décadas en una
dictadura un país donde los únicos
grupos de oposición organizados eran los
hermanos musulmanes y los salafistas del
partido alnoor así que a que no adivinan
quién ganó las elecciones efectivamente
los hermanos musulmanes liderados por
este señor que veis en la pantalla que
se llama mohamed morsi
pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
son mucho más complejas veréis a no ser
que seas arabia saudita y el petróleo te
salga por las orejas el fanatismo
islámico no es la mejor receta económica
para un país así que en menos de un año
la economía de egipto se vino abajo
miles de personas se fueron al paro y la
inflación se disparó
[Música]
mientras tanto las únicas preocupaciones
de mort si eran islamizar el estado y
acabar con la división de poderes para
blindar su poder con nuevas funciones
para el presidente a esto hay que
sumarle el ejército como hemos visto
antes las fuerzas armadas egipcias no se
llevan muy bien con los grupos
islamistas y así es como aparece en
escena este otro señor que vemos en la
pantalla
el mariscal abdel fattah él sí sí el por
entonces jefe de las fuerzas armadas
[Música]
el sisi se reunió con todos los partidos
que estaban en la oposición incluidos
los salafistas y les dijo venir aquí y
mirar estos señores están hundiendo el
país así que ayudadme para organizar un
golpe de estado y volver a poner las
cosas en orden y como decimos en visual
político dicho y hecho
tierra de faraones en el año 2014 el
ejército egipcio echó amor sí del
gobierno y su primera medida fue volver
a ilegalizar a los hermanos musulmanes
por supuesto que hubo protestas cientos
de muertos y miles de detenidos pero en
el mes de junio de ese mismo año se
convocaron nuevas elecciones
y digo elecciones entre comillas porque
el único candidato era el sí sí que ganó
con un 97 por ciento de los votos
[Música]
en realidad había un segundo candidato
aceptado por el régimen y pensaba hill
un periodista egipcio con nulas
posibilidades de ganar las elecciones de
hecho sólo sacó un 3% de los votos
[Música]
recordáis esa frase que decían en el
caballero oscuro o mueres como un héroe
o pides lo suficiente para verte
convertido en el villano pues esa parece
ser la máxima de él sí sí de hecho en
los últimos años egipto ha sido el país
que más condenas de muerte ha decretado
en todo el planeta pero no sólo eso en
sólo tres años el gobierno ha cerrado
más de 27.000 mezquitas y la libertad de
prensa es prácticamente inexistente y ya
se lo que estáis pensando que los
integristas islámicos estarán en pie de
guerra verdad pues lo cierto es que no
recordáis lo que os decíamos de los
hermanos musulmanes y los salafistas que
se llevan a matar pues no era ninguna
broma
[Música]
los islamistas ultraconservadores de
egipto respaldan a sí sí buscando
eclipsar a la hermandad pero esperad un
momento porque las cosas tampoco pintan
bien para los artistas por supuesto que
él sí sí les ha dado carta blanca para
que puedan ocupar los huecos que han
dejado los hermanos musulmanes
en otras palabras que todos los egipcios
creyentes que quieran ir a las mezquitas
tienen que acudir a las que controlan el
imán hato de lázaro que a su vez está
controlado por el estado pero sabéis
cuál es el problema que cada vez hay
menos creyentes en egipto tal cual como
lo oís para que os hagáis una idea el
porcentaje de jóvenes que hacen sus
oraciones diarias ha caído a menos de la
mitad en menos de cinco años
según el barómetro árabe en el año 2011
el 84% de la población apoyaba la sharía
en 2016 ese porcentaje ha caído al 34
por ciento
y no sólo eso el propio el sisi celebra
la navidad cristiana en la catedral
copta de el cairo año tras año en otras
palabras que la sociedad egipcia se está
secularizando a marchas forzadas pero
esperad un momento porque esta evolución
podría dar marcha atrás en cualquier
momento de entrada la popularidad del
cicy ha caído en este año 2017
a buena parte de los egipcios no les ha
sentado nada bien que hayas tenido ante
arabia saudita la soberanía sobre dos
islas en el mar rojo
tampoco les agrada que la represión no
decaiga es más noticias como ésta
recuerdan a los tiempos de mu van as
egipto declara el estado de emergencia
después de los ataques mortales a las
iglesias por otro lado la principal
preocupación de los egipcios con
diferencia es la economía aunque el
desempleo está bajando todavía está por
encima del 12% y esto según las cifras
oficiales ya que extraoficialmente se
cree que la tasa supera el 20%
sin embargo el gobierno parece embarcado
en proyectos faraónicos
egipto construirá una nueva capital
financiada por china si a esto le
sumamos los ataques terroristas y el
hecho de que los hermanos musulmanes
saben moverse muy bien en la
clandestinidad tenemos que el gobierno
del cicy está fracasando en muchos
aspectos
así que la pregunta es creéis que egipto
puede convertirse efectivamente en un
país secular al igual que su vecina
túnez o él sí sí no es más que un
regreso a la etapa anterior a la
primavera árabe y volveremos a ver una
contrarrevolución islámica podéis
dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y si queréis conocer lo que
ha ocurrido en túnez hacer clic en este
vídeo y por supuesto no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribimos al canal para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto